this is the fifth time he's had this
treatment but 45 year old googie it's
old hat as the micro catheters are
attached to his skull who's chatting
away happily but the technique his
doctors are using his groundbreaking to
try and overcome problems of getting
cancer drugs into the brain there's a
natural barrier from the bloodstream
into the brain which blocks poisons
which is useful for us but also blocks
the chemotherapy getting into treat the
tumor so over a number of years my team
in conjunction with a company called
renishaw have developed a system of tiny
tubes which we can use to drive drugs
directly into the brain and to get this
chemotherapy right into the target this
home video was shot shortly after he was
diagnosed last year having almost
overnight begun to have problems with
speech vision and walking the issue is
that research funding goes to the more
prevalent types of cancer whereas
googies brain stem tumor it's
comparatively rare so fundraisers want
to raise nearly a million pounds for
clinical trials through crowdfunding
well it takes quite a long time to get
grant funding and because the nature of
the condition of a dipg tumor means that
it really is a race against the clock to
try and get this child started so to go
through all the traditional processes is
obviously if we had to do that we would
but we really want to try and get this
moving as quickly as possible before
previous doses of chemo have helped
googie the tumor is smaller his visions
improved and he can now walk unaided his
father is delighted but understandably
still uncertain about his future I saw
the results there are there are a huge
results because the amount of the Irate
action is his incredible high and and I
hope it's sufficiently it's enough to to
this thread the tumor most children were
the tumor like googies died within nine
months but it's now 14 months since his
diagnosis and with the new technique he
has a fighting chance Nick Ravenscroft
Sky News